this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
we help you live your best life by being
healthy relationally successful
professionally and peaceful financially
open phones this hour it's a free call
for you triple eight eight two five five
two two five is the number to call i'm
george campbell joined today by my
colleague ken coleman and we are excited
to talk with you about whatever's going
on in your life maybe you've got a
career decision to make that seems to be
a theme lately ken a lot of people
moving to looking to switch careers i'm
going to move over here i'm more remote
now i can go anywhere what do i do the
options are endless we can help you
narrow that down
maybe you've got some money decisions to
make you're trying to get this budget
dialed in you're feeling the weight of
inflation you want to get rid of some
debt you made a bad decision we are here
to help you we're not here to judge you
and we want to to be that helpful friend
that you can call for advice
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number to call we're excited
to talk with you ken you just came off
hot on your show how'd that go well we
had a good time today and you know one
of the things we talked about uh we we
shared a story
um that new data is out that we've got
managers okay so leadership level of of
the corporate structure whether it be
small business or you know on up into
large businesses are also leaving at the
same rate as
you know america's workers so quick
snapshot on what we're talking about
here
so since august of 2021
up to december of 2021 we got the latest
numbers
each month august september october
november december we've had over four
million people leave their jobs wow all
of those months by the way four million
plus to make the math easy each one of
those
are records
so previously we never had that many
people quit their jobs now they're not
quitting and going home and drinking sun
tea and hanging in the hammock we've got
this big musical chairs thing happening
remember that game george oh you're
younger than me well i'm a millennial
but we had that one you strike me as
somebody by the way is is as small and
as nimble as you are that you probably
did very well as musical chairs oh
sneaky man you could just get right in
there on the edge so what's happening is
so so how does this affect the audience
and their money
so
wages are increasing
all right because of two factors okay
you've got your normal inflationary
pressures
that the supply chain
and the disruptions and things that the
pandemic created that's one factor but
the other factor is
coming you know i would say largely uh
in the middle back half of the first
year of the pandemic
we saw big companies walmart target best
buy and beyond raised their minimum wage
now not the federal minimum wage but
they just said we're going to raise our
minimum wage you're going to start at
jobs at these companies at 15 an hour
all right so fast forward you see one do
it another does it another does another
does it and so we go okay we're going to
increase our wages because we want to
touch people back to work
so this all starts to happen and it just
kind of builds on itself
and so people start going wait a second
i can make three to five bucks more an
hour over here i'm gonna go over here or
i can make 15 20 more over here i'm
gonna go over here so when they leave it
creates a hole the musical chairs we all
get this so then companies the only way
they get people is
the dollar
so as a result we are in the greatest
boom
of salary or financial opportunity
related to your work
so if you're thinking about this folks i
can help you with this so we'll help you
today i mean you want to talk about a
big shovel as dave created this idea of
the more money we make our income is our
greatest wealth building tool you know
your job yeah and so it's also the
greatest opportunity for you to get out
of debt and so now is a great time but
all that said we cover the fact that
leaders are leaving too
because as people are leaving george it
creates okay we've got a hole now i've
got to fill it but i've also got to take
care of the people that are here
and so there's also pressure coming from
executive leadership or the small
business owner for those middle managers
or leaders they've got
pressure coming from the top to perform
then they've got pressure from below
them with the team going hey i need more
man you're you're asking me to do 20
more i'm not making more you know mental
health burnout all those things are real
and then of course you get the customer
coming at you directly so
it's a disheartening piece of data
because
as we know here at ramsey solutions
leadership is the glue yeah of an
organization and so we've got a lot of
burnout for leaders too and that's
disheartening and so we reported on that
and of course we we deal with that on
the ken coleman show every day and of
course andre leadership are
you know wildly popular
leadership division ramsey solutions and
the entree leadership podcast i i
couldn't recommend that enough you host
that uh to give leaders the tools
because it's all about people
that's right great reminders there
fascinating situation yeah so we
reported on that yeah
well let's go to the phones this hour
cleveland ohio is where we go joe joins
us there joe welcome to the ramsay show
hey how you doing this afternoon joe
from freezing cold cleveland ohio how
can we help today let's warm you up i
had a question i'm 61 years old semi
retired and my father passed away about
a year ago
and he left an ira for me which is
approximately six figures i don't have a
lot of savings in the bank account
nothing like that my house is paid off
in full
so i don't have a lot of expenses
praise my father in heaven that listen
to him so everything's paid off
but would you recommend cashing out an
ira like that or living off of it a
little bit i don't really have any much
coming in maybe some social security in
a few years because i'm 61. yeah so you
don't have any savings any retirement
savings
no i don't i was kind of a self-employed
guy back here and back there and
you know over the years you know okay
yeah it sounds like you got some
background noise there i don't know if
you can shut that off so we can hear you
nice and clear
nice let me turn this truck off maybe
that's a little bit there we go okay so
joe how much is in the ira
it's about a hundred thousand okay
well considering you don't have any
retirement savings this feels like this
is gonna be partially your retirement
savings
correct so i wouldn't go cash it all out
and just have it sitting in cash that
feels like a bad idea uh i would i would
let that continue to be invested make
sure that it's being invested in good
growth stock mutual funds in there as
you head into your retirement years
you're gonna have to live off something
and social security isn't gonna cut it
right yeah that's very true
so how long do you plan on working for
well i probably work now i run run some
tow trucks and i help guys sell cars and
things so i can maybe do that another 10
years i'm hoping i'm
kind of healthy guy you know don't smoke
don't drink don't do all that crazy
stuff hey joe what would you say because
you you're doing several things or what
would you say
is an average yearly income for you now
and what do you think it could be for
the next 10 years knowing we've got to
start really you're debt-free so now
it's just piling on this this retirement
account what do you think you can make
what are you making
approximately maybe 45 50 working
part-time a year you know yeah
so a lot of expenses yeah so let me i'm
just asking more challenging i think one
of the questions you've got to ask is
uh you're healthy you said you know i
think you're still a young man
um
yeah absolutely it's perspective what if
you worked full time how much more money
this is the thing you gotta answer on
your own this is your homework
assignment how much more money could you
make working a full schedule are there
some more desirable jobs given the holes
in this economy
uh where you can make even more and
start to fast forward the retirement
contribution joe if you don't have any
savings i definitely want you to park
some of that take some of that out as an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses beyond that i want you to
invest and use this money that was left
to you as a blessing to kickstart a new
retirement fund a new future for joe
that's what i want for you to retire
with dignity and not be stressed out
once you're unable to work or no longer
want to work this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business
that's why we use netsuite by oracle the
number one cloud financial system over
28 000 companies use netsuite by oracle
including ramsey solutions because
netsuite gives us a single view of
everything we need to make daily
decisions whether you're making a few
million to hundreds of millions a year
netsuite gives you the visibility and
control of the things you need to grow
like your financials inventory hr
planning budgeting and more all in one
dashboard go to netsuite.com ramsey
right now to get their free white paper
jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm
ramsey personality george campbell host
of the fine print and entree leadership
podcast joined today by my pal ken
coleman host of the ken coleman show
best-selling author and we are here for
you america what do you want to talk
about
money career life we can do it all we
are happy to help walk you through
whatever is on your mind whatever's
keeping you up at night you need a
little confirmation
we got you george i just thought you
know i'd sweeten the pot a little bit
okay if people are a little nervous
they're going hey i'm not where i want
to be in my profession i want to make
more money i want to get a bigger shovel
maybe just like ken how can i make more
money to get out of the baby steps
faster if you call in today and you have
a job-related question guaranteed we're
going to give you a copy of my latest
best-selling book from paycheck to
purpose so if you've got that kind of a
call we're just going to go ahead and
give you that book too which will help
you no matter where you're at in your
journey now call with a real question
don't be real you're not getting through
kelly without that no well that's
assumed good good way to sweet and
millennials gen z if you're going away i
got a call there's a so there's an app
on the phone ken i don't know if you've
seen this it has a picture of a phone
which you may not even know what that
picture is it's like the old school
phone and if you tap that you can dial
the number triple eight eight two five
five two two five and you will hopefully
be connected with the wonderful kelly
and she will put you on with us to help
you out so the number to call triple
eight eight two five five two two five
let's have a conversation will is ready
to do that this will is ready as i say
it will appear boston massachusetts my
hometown i'm very excited will how you
doing
hi thanks for having me on the show i'm
a big fan awesome to speak to you though
we are excited to talk with you how can
ken and i help
uh
so quickly um i'm in the middle of a job
change
i'm not so i was working at a major
hospital here and i got let go because
of the
cove mandates
and
i have a new job opportunity in another
hospital in a different part of the
country
and they also have a similar mandate in
place and i'm trying to decide whether
to
even go down an interview
um
i was hoping to get ken's perspective on
how do i
how do i align my values
with this choice of decision yeah
well if i'm understanding you correctly
these you're looking at doing something
similar to what you were doing just at a
different hospital in a different state
yeah because i i loved the work i was
doing which is a big family for a long
time and i've you know that passion and
purpose it hit all the all the boxes so
what were you doing what is that work
that you're passionate about describe it
to me
uh well
i guess
so i'm an academic researcher okay um
i've been doing this work for 20 years
and it's it's in
medical technology okay that's what you
specialize in trying to help people yeah
you specialize in in the research in
medical technology
yeah okay great and that's part of the
problem is very specialized i mean
there's probably 10 places in the
country that do what i do oh really okay
all right now that is a challenge but i
want us to so the reason i'm taking you
here
is because here let's talk about the
realities
i've not seen anything in the in the
headlines that tells me
that that hospital systems let's just
call it that
are going to
remove a vaccine mandate anytime soon
would you agree with that statement is
that close to actually i agree with that
statement yeah all right so we've got a
challenge
then we've got the challenge of ken what
i do is so highly specialized and you've
narrowed it down to there's only 10
organizations that even hire somebody
like you is that what i'm to understand
well that do this work i mean so the the
flip side is is that my skills are very
applicable to us yes
absolutely
right i mean so my wife jokes that i was
unemployed for a day and a half right
exactly no because i got i got
terminated and then right the next
monday i had a new
new job at a different company but doing
different work right so i'm glad you
said that because we'll let me just tell
you what i think
i'm not i listen i get hammered on the
ken coleman show on this on the vaccine
mandate but i'm not a doctor nor have i
ever played one on tv i will tell you
that i would like to wear scrubs to work
i got to tell you i think you can pull
it off if dave would allow that i'm in
uh i would wear scraps but i don't i'm
not gonna ever give anybody advice on
anything medical whether i'm passionate
about an opinion or not so i'm not gonna
do that what i will tell you is you know
what you believe why you believe
and then how you think you should live
based on that true or false
you know that true i mean it's so
i owe you and and dave ramsey a huge
huge thank you because i've been
listening for about three years and i
was set up in such a way that i could
make my own choice and choose my own
destiny right so don't change it i'm
just not sure how to proceed because i'm
eating and offered a job that i would
really like this job well ask a point
blank ask them point blank because
you're not my here's what i'm saying
i'm not going to tell you what you
should do about the vaccine mandate
that's your call but you've already told
us what you feel you lost your job
because you said i'm not going to take
it
yeah so if you've changed your mind
or if you're willing to change your mind
then i say no challenge but i don't
think that's what's going on
so if they've offered you this you get
on the phone and go hey guys thanks for
the offer here's the deal
i'm not comfortable taking it here's why
if that's a sticking point i'm not here
to fight you
but i just need to let you know that up
front what do you have to lose
nothing
it's more of so i mean there is a there
is an exemption process that i could go
through
my wife's big concern is is that
if i take this job what's to say that
i'm not going to leave it in a in a year
over what because the
over so the exemptions are temporary
right so i could get the exemption this
month and get hired and move the family
down
but then in the year again
her concern is is what god how do we
trust that the company won't do the same
thing well we can't in a year we
so therein lies what are you have
let's go back to what we said i think i
think the balance of our conversation
and really how i can help you is simply
this you said early on in the call that
your research skills
and your experience are very valuable
and transferable and i think you have to
broaden your horizons the fact of the
matter is you have an incredible resume
uh and so you are a very attractive
candidate to who knows how many
companies who just need an absolute you
know uh bloodhound of a dog that can
just sniff it out research it figure it
out make good suggestions whatever it is
that's what you're really great at doing
and so that has all kinds of benefits
and there are private companies that are
in that medical space obviously that one
makes sense but i think you got to open
yourself up to so many different
industries you are a world-class
researcher and as long as you get to
research something you're interested in
that has a direct impact on people that
you can connect your values to you know
this is what i teach then it's open
season go for it but don't subject
yourself and your family to this move if
it's going to uproot everybody and then
we're back in the same place a year from
now i think you must take control
control what you can control i'm looking
in other industries and other companies
that aren't going to require the mandate
right that's it that's what you're left
with okay
or that or you go get the bags i mean
you can still love the work you were
doing somewhere else i think it's a
false narrative that gosh i loved it so
much there i'm never gonna find that
again because remember what i teach you
have talent that's what you do best you
have passion work you love to do
and then you have a sense of mission
results you want to contribute to the
world you can find that in other
industries outside of medicine true or
false
true
absolutely true
so appreciate the call but you can do
this but you've got to do what's right
for you and your family and don't feel
the pressure to just take this one
opportunity
but i would also say
that
you have financial freedom and if the
family's willing to make a move and we
see what happens a year from now that's
not a giant risk either other than just
a kind of a pain to kind of move the
family around so there's a little bit of
a relational family component to this
answer that i can't answer for you and
your wife got to decide yeah i'm feeling
the same thing if i'm in will's shoes
i'm making the move i'm not going to be
as worried about the well what if in a
year i'm just going to make the move if
they're willing to have me and i like
being honest and the family's willing to
move yeah because there is a risk there
of you know uprooting again and i love
that he's not wanting to waste anyone's
time just up front say hey here's where
i stand would you guys be willing to
take me yeah and if they say yeah we
make the move with the exemption process
and move forward with it i hope that he
loves it thanks for the call will a
little taste of the ken coleman show
right here on the mother ship the ramsay
show for you this morning so make sure
to check out ken show if you've got
career challenges that you are facing
ken would love to talk with you on his
show you can get more information about
that at kencoleman.com by the way we owe
will a book a copy of my best-selling
book
hang on kelly will get it we got you
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five we'd love to
hear from you this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell joined today by ramsay
personality ken coleman it's tax season
folks and many of you have been filing
your taxes with the same software for
years but are you sick and tired of the
add-on fees they sneak in there yeah
you've probably seen all the ads saying
it's for you to do your taxes with the
big companies but the reality is that
for most people it's not free
by the time you realize you don't meet
the free criteria you've put in too much
time to start over somewhere else so you
pay up folks they're making a killing
off of you that way we think you deserve
better and that's why we are offering
ramsay smart tax so you can file your
taxes online without paying more than
you'd expect ramsey smart tax includes
every form you need with no hidden fees
and no surprises we even have a promo
code right now so you can file your
federal taxes for free and if you prefer
to have priority support and extended
audit protection you can go with our
premium version for just 20 bucks
if you're ready to ditch the other guys
surprising fees and save on your taxes
go to ramseysolutions.com smart tax and
get started today that's ramsey
solutions dot com slash smart tax
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com their 100 satisfaction
guarantee means even if you mismeasure
or pick the wrong color they'll remake
your blinds for free you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use promo code ramsay to get
the best deal today's question comes
from andrew in new york i'm 25 years old
and i work in accounts payable for an
hvac refrigeration company making 52 000
a year i dislike sitting in an office
all day and i dread going to work
there's no room for growth other than
two raises a year that's
you don't hear of two raises a year very
often let's keep reading i've been
considering the possibility of
transitioning into a role as a mechanic
in the field i've already spoken to the
supervisor who said i could transition
to being a mechanic once i received my
epa certification i would take a five
dollar an hour pay cut at first but
mechanics earn much more and get six
raises a year
i would be making more than i am now by
this time next year if i start soon i
think i would enjoy the work in the
field more since i enjoy being outside
and moving around
should i transition into a completely
new career with an opportunity for much
higher pay before you decide
i want you to spend some time with a
minimum of three
mechanics in the hvac refrigeration
field so that either are three mechanics
from your company because you've already
got some relationships or certainly
inroads or outside of your company i
don't care and i want you to talk to
people enjoy it like not the miserable
hvac mechanic because that's not going
to yield you anything
you know the idea of the right question
to the wrong person still gets you the
wrong answer you got to talk to the
right person who left the right
questions to the right person and that's
somebody who's been doing a while and
enjoys it i want you to just figure uh
as though you are doing a high school or
college term paper with these mechanics
do some research sitting with them
talking about the ins and outs of what
they do the long
the easy the you know the long hours or
the easy work versus the hard work the
awful days the good days get it all
process that and i think your heart's
going to reveal to you whether or not
you would enjoy it if it's a yes
then go ahead and do it yeah when i see
it because i would enjoy it that worries
me yes he may not yeah if he knows he's
going to enjoy it
and he knows that the five five dollar
an hour pay cut is temporary this time
next year he's making a good bit more
that's the kind of go backwards to move
forward move i'm always in favor of this
sounds like an easy move for me i'm
doing it from him as long as we do the
right shadowing and we go yeah i'm all
in yeah but if i was asking this
question george what would your answer
be no ken does not need to be turning
wrenches right why george uh for about a
thousand reasons mostly because it'd be
dangerous for whoever's driving that
vehicle
because i don't have the talent i am you
and i are very grateful for mechanics
out there we are that is why i work hard
so that i can pay a mechanic to do the
work for me there it is i'm not sitting
there on youtube on a saturday trying to
figure out how to change my mind
this is it no thanks tom hanks yeah all
right let's go to the phones this hour
ryan joins us in tempe arizona ryan
welcome to the show how can we help
thanks for having me on guys how are you
guys doing great what's going on with
you
oh i got a kind of a unique housing
question for you okay so i work in tempe
and
i actually drive up three hours from
where i stay and live
uh in the beginning of the week and then
stay the week for work and then drive
back down
and i really want to get a house
around the tempe area okay as you guys
know the uh
the uh
housing market has just gone insane
um
i have no debt
and currently
up in tempe i am staying with
my boss who renovates the house and so
i've been able to slowly been
saving up
for a down payment
but i don't want to overstay my welcome
there sure you want an exit strategy
well not necessarily an exit strategy
but a
i you know
to for me to be able to get a house and
do what you guys suggest with only 25 of
my take-home pay for the
mortgage payment i'm gonna need to
build up a pretty big down payment so i
don't wanna you know bother my boss with
staying there for another
five years or more you got it so what's
your income
so i make 17 an hour
plus as much overtime as i could ever
stack in there okay
and how much down payment do you have
right now do you have any savings
uh
above my
emergency fund i have
five thousand saved cool
okay well i love the idea of you not
driving making that drive every week
that sounds miserable
yeah it's not the most exciting thing
but the other side of this is you want
to buy a house in a very expensive area
while not making a whole lot
and so this is going to be a patient's
game or it's going to be a shovel game
where we go we got to find some more
money
what's the uh what's the number what's
the number that you need to save what's
the whole number
for the right down below
yep
oh about fifty thousand all right so you
have 45 to go right
yes sir okay
um i i'm wondering uh george and i'm
wondering uh ryan uh is the move for you
maybe to move to tempe and rent and
share share a place with somebody so we
we remove this
this this is a this is an emotional and
mental drain right now we need to get
rid of the drive we need to get rid of
the drive and so why not move to tempe
uh if you got a rent with two or three
guys right you're an enterprising guy
you're not a creep you know fine i think
that's my move yeah and then i'll tell
you what else i get out of that move
ryan is is and i have time to kind of
look around find some bargains let the
market cool down let the market maybe
cool down some i wouldn't get too
excited about that but the point is is
like you don't put all this pressure on
yourself to buy when you move to tempe
let's get to tempe make life better by
virtue of the drive being better and
then i got to tell you with all that
overtime that you can get and the fact
that you have no debt
45 000 george it's doable let's run the
numbers yeah how quickly could he
actively save 45 000. how much margin do
you have right now ryan at the end of
the month to throw at the down payment
with all the overtime and everything
uh so
how much margin do you have how much you
throwing into that savings account for
the down payment every month
so every month i save about a thousand
two hundred
okay so 1200 bucks a month is what
you're saving right now
so that's about 15 grand a year
and you need 45. so it's three grand if
we just stay at that excuse me three
years if we stay at that pace yeah
ryan so the question now ryan is how do
we speed it up even further and i love
the idea of renting with roommates in
tempe to avoid the drive give you a
little bit of even more margin
are you paying rent right now or is he
letting you stay there for free
uh he lets me stay there for free so
that's how i'm how i'm putting away over
half my paycheck awesome okay all right
well that changes some but how old are
you ryan
i am turning 26 next week
yeah i mean is it that big of a deal to
save up for two or three years
and wait and your income will go up in
those years right
it should yes
right now and they
i'm in the manufacturing world okay
well i'd be looking uh
for a salary position okay
where you can make more which will speed
up this process and you can get
roommates but i i think the idea of
staying with at the boss's place for
three years like you said feels a little
bit
a little tight i don't love that idea
so let's try to find a solution here it
may be a patience game it may take you
three years to do this but it's
absolutely doable uh even with your
income so stay the course man and the
fact that you're debt-free you've got
the emergency fund
just shows you can do this stuff
regardless of your income whether you
make a hundred thousand a year or forty
thousand a year this stuff works way to
go man rooting for you this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you are listening to the ramsay show i'm
ramsay personality george campbell
joined today by my good pal ken coleman
and we are taking your calls america so
ring us up triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the number to call
hannah joins us in seattle washington
hannah welcome to the ramsay show
hello hey how can i ken and i help today
um i was just calling in because i
recently got engaged and
i was wondering what the best way to
encourage my partner to
branch out and try and figure out what
he might want to do as a career would be
um
right now he just
it's
it's a good job but it's not a going
anywhere have room for improvement or
financial gain type of job and he's just
very comfortable he's been there for
four years
and i don't want to see maggie but i i
do want to encourage him to try and
figure out what he might want to do for
the rest of our life has he told you he
does not enjoy it
no he
doesn't
hate it but he doesn't love it it's just
kind of
uh it's a job where he has a lot of
wiggle room so he can pretty much work
as much overtime as you want
and
and he's not working any over time
no he does every single day actually
like two or four hours every day but um
but you're saying it doesn't show much
financial opportunity beyond what he's
doing yeah
right yeah and you and he seems very
close four years i think you've gotten
two raises and
um they weren't large or small raises
they were just kind of middle of the
road but yeah what's the conversation
been like between the two of you around
this because i i know you've talked
about it based the way you're setting
this call up yeah what give me a quick
summary of how it goes
um
you know i'll ask him like oh do you
have any like goals or dreams or
passions
and then
it that's when it kind of falls dead
what does he say nothing at all
no i mean he'll
he'll say oh i don't really know what i
want to do or
you know i have a lot of
perks
at this job that i might not get at
other jobs because like if he asks for a
day off he gets the day off right
granted he doesn't take many days off
right so so it sounds like he's got a
good work ethic
yeah he does yeah
well so let me address this
if you had passion somewhere else you
could succeed so quick and you could
but
i love the heart of your question so
here you are you're in this really
interesting relationship
uh
role where you want to be an encourager
but it can quickly become
and i don't want to use the word nagging
you use the word nagging i understand
what you said but i think it becomes you
go from encourager to
irritator right and and and it's like
when you bring it up the reason he drops
off of it really quickly is people don't
like to talk about something
that makes them uncomfortable
right
unless you're just some psychotic you
know jerk you know who likes to make
people uncomfortable so any of whether
it be politics religion whatever any
kind of topic at work when a person just
doesn't feel comfortable talking about
it they shut down would you agree with
that
yeah and so the reason he's
uncomfortable talking about it and shuts
down is because he doesn't have an
answer
and he might very well get defensive
pretty quickly because he's like why are
you asking that
and so what happens is when you bring it
up instead of being this
you know person who's behind him and i
know you are and this person who's
supporting him and i know you are and a
person who cares and is cheering for i
know you're doing all that but he
doesn't see it that way he sees it as
the person who keeps making me feel
uncomfortable so i want you i want you
to understand the psychology in this
conversation
so
there's no like one two three four
things that i could give you that you do
for him but i think what you've got to
stop doing is asking questions like you
know
what are you dreaming about or what do
you want to do professionally because he
you already know he doesn't have an
answer
what you've got to do is
is have the conversation a little bit
more fun and light-hearted and in good
hit him in the right times with you know
what are you what are you have you ever
dreamed about something i was dreaming
about this the other day like start
talking about what you're dreaming about
start talking about what maybe you're
passionate about and then he's not
feeling like
i'm i have to come up with an answer for
her he starts to hear you and then
you're kind of making it fun and going
if money didn't matter what would you do
just that age-old question you know what
i mean did you ever dream about
something when you were 18
now that's one way to do it okay
the other way to do it is i really want
you
to uh you don't have to tell him you
called this show but i want you to give
i'm going to give you a copy of my brand
new book it's a bestseller called from
paycheck to purpose and it helps people
see how do i get clear on that answer
what do i want to do
what would i be passionate about and
then how do i do it so it's it's the
seven stages of how you do that and then
i also want to give you a link to our
get clear career assessment and this is
an assessment that'll be fun for him to
take because it's less than 20 minutes
and just say hey if you take this this
is going to spit out a purpose statement
that we can kind of then have some fun
with and it's low key low pressure it's
going to tell you what you do best if
that's talent it's going to tell you
what work you love to do that's passion
and it's going to show you what results
you care about from your work that's
mission and and let him take that and
then have a fun conversation about the
results
and have him go talk to a couple other
people besides you
about his purpose statement and then go
you know what this guy ken says he says
if you take that purpose statement it
becomes like a job description
and and so now all of a sudden it's very
relaxed
fun no pressure for him
i think that's the best you can do you
can no longer make him feel any pressure
or feel like he's got to give you a
clear answer around this conversation so
i'm going to give you both of those
resources because that way it's not like
hey and by the way you read this and
then tell me what you come up with just
go hey you know what i've asked you
about this before i listen to this this
show whatever whatever and just go hey
check this assessment out don't ask him
to read the book have him take the
assessment if he wants to do more then
give him the book i love it great
resources
hannah i'm just curious is there a
question behind the question here is
there like a number like man i just
i i love this guy and i feel like he
deserves better he should be making more
money i want to see him with more drive
and excitement what is there something
behind that for you
well i
right when the pandemic hit i was lucky
enough to get a job at a company
that i won't name just because of who
they are but
um they have a lot of benefits and one
of the benefits they offer their
employees is the schooling benefit which
i
jumped on immediately good and
i um through listening to your show
actually i'm really excited to read
paycheck to purpose because i have an
idea of the path that i want to go on
but
there are some unknown factors that
don't
that i don't know for sure if it's going
to be the perfect fit for me so reading
that hopefully will help me
by the way when you start when you start
to get enlightenment along the journey
just share it with him you see what i'm
saying yeah totally but hey george is in
george is on to something i think you're
afraid that if he stays where he is you
all aren't going to be able to have the
life you want to live that's what i
think i hear
a little bit that and also
just
i just want him to be as excited about
something as i am i guess and maybe i
don't know if that's selfish
but i just know
when i start because i want to become a
nutritionist or a dietitian
i struggled with weight as a child and
i'd like to get into a field where i can
help children also to learn about
nutrition
before they have to go through that
struggle of being overweight as a kid
and
so i guess i just want him to have
something to do
let me tell you something you're not
selfish
but i'm telling you
he needs to just catch it he needs to
see how joyful you are
and instead of feeling pressure from you
he just needs to feel motivated by you
because he goes wow i want what she's
eating you know i love the idea of you
guys reading this thing together too
maybe maybe
and ultimately it would be amazing if we
could maybe even be interested in
something similar or that works together
because i would love nothing more than
to have our own business and be able to
work
so start sharing that dream with you
hannah's dreaming that's who we like to
see she just got to get her fiance on
board
she's got ideas for tests well hannah
hang on kelly will pick up and we'll get
you a copy of from paycheck to purpose
and ken's get clear assessment that will
be immensely helpful that puts this hour
of the ramsey show in the books my
thanks to my co-host ken coleman the
whole team in the booth keeping the show
running so smoothly and you america we
appreciate you guys listening so very
much we'll be back with you before you
know it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
we help you live your best life by being
healthy relationally successful
professionally and peaceful financially
i'm ramsey personality george campbell
joined today by my good friend
ken coleman best-selling author host of
the ken coleman show and we are excited
to take your calls the number to call is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five
clinton kicks us off in detroit michigan
clinton welcome to the show
hi how are you doing doing great how can
ken and i help
um so right now i'm in a particular
situation where i have a couple options
when it comes to buying my first home
okay cool um
i could either
wait and save up more money and not buy
a home this year which i'm never against
or
i could get started with a starter home
and spend the next i know personally by
myself in michigan i could probably get
that done the mortgage done in about
three to five years by myself but i am
recently married last year
and
i'm just wondering if
since i can get it done and it would
still be affordable if i should maybe
bump that up about 50 to 100 000 more
dollars on a mortgage loan and get
started on a family house which uh me
and my wife can plan to live in in the
next 25 to 30 years and kind of grow
into the home
so
i'm just wondering which option might be
best for me right now okay what's the
household income
um right now
i make about 120 000
my wife will be graduating this semester
to be a nurse
awesome so you guys are going to have a
great income
yeah it's going to work out pretty well
i love that okay and you guys are debt
free do we have any debt on the table
right now
i do have uh i do have a card note that
is gonna
i still have about 13 000 on that
and my wife is going to have about 20
000 in student loan debt that um she
will be we already have a budget set for
her to pay that off within a year okay
and that's all the debt do you guys have
any savings right now in the emergency
fund
yes i have about 25 000 saved up right
now
okay and then do you have a down payment
fund outside of that
no okay so that's all the numbers here i
just want to get clear so clinton i love
the idea of you buying a home and i
personally would start with that smaller
starter home if you guys are patient you
want to get a home that you know is
going to be able to fit there's a lot of
what-ifs here uh with buying
i don't like the term forever home
because there's really no such thing i
mean we can plan on
life happening and we lived there for 30
years and it's happily ever
happily ever after but a lot of life can
happen in 30 years and so i don't like
to plan in that way but what i am saying
here is if you have you been listening
to us for a while
no i just recently started about two
weeks or so okay cool we have a process
called the baby steps and this is the
same one that you'll hear in financial
peace university that's helped 10
million people and these are steps that
are in order focused intensity one at a
time that build incrementally and it
starts with baby step one where you get
a thousand dollars in a starter
emergency fund now obviously you have
that off to the side
baby step two is the debt snowball where
we pay off all of our consumer debt from
smallest to largest regardless of the
interest rate
and then
outside of that we build the fully
funded emergency fund that you currently
have so right now we're trying to do
like 17 things at once like when i try
to talk to my wife while she's sending a
text
there's nothing you just she just cannot
and so same thing with jason yeah yeah
interesting now men are just as guilty
but that's my that's my example so
here's the thing i want you to do these
steps in order because i know they work
and they work for me and i'm here at
baby step seven and i've got a paid for
home and so i'm gonna talk to you as if
i was talking to a myself or a good
friend
you've got 25 000 and you have 33 000 in
debt correct
yes just about and you make a fantastic
income so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to take 24 of that 25 000
and i'm going to attack the the car loan
get rid of that and i'm going to start
to attack the student loan
okay and that's going to take that debt
down to barely anything when do you get
married
i got married last year you're already
married okay i misunderstood and then
she's gonna be getting out of nursing
school when
uh may of this year okay guys and you
guys are renting right now
yeah we're renting i'm paying about 1200
a month okay
all right so that's that's the plan
we're gonna get rid of all that debt
before we then save up for the fully
funded emergency fund which would be
three to six months of expenses
depending on your situation if you both
got stable incomes you can lean towards
three if there's some outliers there
some health issues i would lean towards
six
then and only then would i tell you to
save up for a down payment on a house
which is step three b
and at that point that's when you go all
right now we're ready to sock away some
money and guess what you have freed up a
lot of payments haven't you by getting
rid of that car loan and a student loan
and by the way your wife is probably
going to be working as a nurse by then
right
yeah for sure just in a couple months so
quickly 200 grand to no payments yeah
but so after you put the 24 on there as
george told you to clinton how fast i
mean just run this through your head
let's say you did all this today because
you could you could take the 24 000.
wipe out the car loan right
and that's done today and by the way
george and i think you should do that
today today and then you put the rest on
the loan you have nine nine thousand
left over how quickly could you pay off
that nine thousand just running a quick
budget in your head how quickly
um remember you freed up the car loan
payment
even even sooner than a half a year
exactly four to five months what's your
car payment right now
my car payment is well i pay 500 a month
but i really only have to pay like three
right so the point is you take the 500
and you're putting it towards the 9 000.
at a minimum you're doing 500 you can do
more than that right right so you and
your wife are getting after this and man
before you know it you're completely
debt free then you move forward you got
this this is exciting i mean you've been
listening to the show for a couple weeks
you're you have a chance to make some
huge gains
right right so i shouldn't be too
worried about the fact that i'm spending
1200 a month in rent right now no so
there's a sentiment out there that
you're throwing away money on rent and i
hate that sentiment so much because it
causes people to jump into a house
before they're financially ready and
then they call the show and go ken
george my mortgage is 50 of my my
take-home pay and i'm broke
should i sell the house and i don't want
to hear that call from you man you're
doing so great
so when it comes to the house i want you
to stick to a 15-year fixed-rate
mortgage with a payment that's no more
than 25 of your take-home pay and that's
absolutely doable especially when your
wife's working so i would let the dust
settle get rid of this debt figure out
what her income is going to be and then
base it on that we've got a great
mortgage calculator at
ramseysolutions.com click on free tools
and start playing around with that
and with a 15-year fixed rate mortgage
go all right we're going to try to put
20 down or more on this house and here's
here's what that payment would be which
means right now we can afford this much
house and six months from now we can
afford even more house and you you're a
patient man you just told me you're
willing to wait and i love that yeah
because that gives you options and
options gives you peace hey you know
what i think we should give him a copy
of total money makeover
this is the plan
okay you're new to us but let's give you
you george told you what to do but
here's the book that's going to help you
and your wife get on the same page so
hang on the line kelly will get you a
copy of total money makeover and boy you
guys are going to be millionaires before
you can possibly imagine because of this
free journey this is awesome all right
hang on kelly will pick up we will get
you taken care of a man thank you for
the call this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm
ramsay personality george campbell
joined today by ken coleman you know we
just took a call about housing and real
estate let me tell you
if you've made one of those dumb
decisions with zeros on the end because
you didn't do your research yeah i've
been there
most people make choices based on
feelings and opinions especially when
buying a house it can get real emotional
but when it comes to the real estate
market feelings aren't your friend facts
are so check your facts find out what
you can actually afford and research
what's trending in home prices and talk
to a reputable real estate agent in your
area never buy a house without the facts
again go to ramseysolutions.com
agent and work with an agent who will
help you make smart decisions that's
ramsay solutions dot com slash agent
k joins us in columbus ohio kay welcome
to the ramsay show
thank you for taking my call absolutely
um
i'm kind of in a hard place here
my daughter-in-law wants to get on the
envelope system
and but she's so far in debt and i don't
know how to help her and i want to give
her hope that she can if she will buckle
down and you know really work at it okay
i don't i don't know how to help her get
started
so she's she's willing to she's excited
about this process yes how much debt
does she have do you know
um i think about 30 000
okay what kind of debt is it
um car loans and
credit card
debt okay and you're saying you want to
help her are you talking about just
encouragement and kind of more
i've tried to help her before giving her
money you know to pay bills and she can
pay me back but that's not working okay
yeah i was gonna say i mean if you were
gonna do this as some kind of gift to
help her out i mean that's a very sweet
thing to do but i feel like she's
wanting to do this on her own
right are you getting the sentiment from
her that that's the that's the case
yes okay well the best thing you can do
is the first part which is encouragement
and support and cheerleading and if
you've ever heard one of our debt-free
screams we always ask who are your
biggest cheerleaders
and you know you could be that for her
through this process you could be
accountability you could be checking in
on her hey how are you doing can i can i
help you with anything what are you
excited about tell me about your wins
and it's you know it can be isolating
following this plan when no one around
you is
and if that's the case you could be that
person she can go to and say oh my gosh
okay you won't believe it i paid off
another thousand dollars of the car loan
today i'm feeling the progress i see the
light at the end of the tunnel this is
awesome
yes would that excite you if you were
that person
oh yes and you follow this plan i assume
and you're you're calling into the show
yes so does she see you as kind of a
mentor in that way of someone who's
followed the plan and are you debt free
yes that's cool
how familiar how familiar with the baby
steps is she since you've done it
she is not
and so i but she just wants to jump in
and do the envelope system but she's so
far in bed i don't know how to even help
her get started well we can do that well
wait a second you sure do know how to
help her get started you did it
give yourself some credit mom you did it
okay you did it okay it's the baby steps
right so where where do where does the
envelope system which is right the
budgeting where does that fall in the
baby steps mom
oh
um
it's a different question i don't know
it's not it's not a trick question
obviously we want to we want to get her
started with a budget right that budget
but what we first want to do is we want
her to get that baby step one we want
her to get a thousand dollars in the
back
yeah you know the baby steps right baby
step two
there we go so have you sat down with
her and actually just even if it's on a
whiteboard on a piece of paper explain
the baby steps and said hey here's how i
got out of debt does she have she heard
that
she has yeah but just sit down and write
it out for her she just needs to see the
clear path right okay the problem is
though okay this is my daughter-in-law
oh i'm sorry okay i can still call you
mom cause you're mom-in-law
that's right yeah all right but okay the
problem is she has her mom in in their
home she's taking care of her mom
so what she does when her mom's social
security checks and things come in she
just puts it in the bank with her
husband's checks and
then it's either feast or famine they go
you know out to eat they spend money
and i
i feel like i'm i can't help her if she
continues to do that
you're right there's got to be some
behavior change here and when she says
she's all in on the plan that means some
sacrifices are being made and that may
mean she needs to get plugged into you
know financial peace university read the
total money makeover i think she needs a
little bit of that
information and inspiration to go all
right i'm angry now i'm excited about
the future and so we are happy to gift
that to you to give to her would that be
cool
no yes okay so here's what i'm gonna do
kelly's gonna pick up i'm gonna send you
an envelope system a physical one that
she can use to actually do this stuff
and i'm gonna get her connected with a
ramsay plus membership for a year so
that she can go through all the videos
in financial peace university and she
needs to do that with her husband
yes and we gotta stop using uh mom's
social security to go out to eat
we gotta be adults we gotta use our
money for our goals and not live like
children and so i hope this plan helps
her um with the envelope system and
ramsay plus to get her on the path and
then you're gonna be her biggest
cheerleader along the way how's that
sound oh absolutely yes oh that sounds
wonderful awesome well kate thank you so
much for the question you've got a great
heart and i'm excited have her call in
when she's dead free and say hey kay
sent me appreciate the plan this stuff
works awesome all right courtney joins
us in boise courtney how are you
hello
oh hello there we go you sound like a
muppet for a second okay how you doing
how can we help
yeah i'm doing okay um
i am calling though
um to get um some financial perspective
um
unfortunately i'm in the middle of a
divorce and um it looks like i'm going
to lose the house
thank you yeah i didn't see it coming at
all
oh no so
how recent is this you know
um
it's been seven months now
sorry so yeah i
thought i'd be able to hold on to the
house because our mortgage payments are
really low and
um you know it's a wonderful community
for the kids and everything
but um when i have to refinance
because i was a stay-at-home mom um i
won't be able to
to get um
a good rate and
um
so so why are you losing the house
well i i just won't be able to
make the payments after it's refinanced
i'm working at a local coffee shop
so
yeah i'm so sorry
yeah
are you going to come out are you going
to come out ahead after you sell the
house what do you stand to make if
anything
yeah well
yes so fortunately um we do have a lot
of equity in it
um
yeah is that being split evenly
it is well i'm assuming it will be
equally yes do you have a lawyer are you
guys going through mediation what's
where are you at in the process
yeah i have a lawyer um we just
uh ended our fourth mediation but we
weren't able to
agree
at first he was going to
in lieu of alimony pay the mortgage
until our oldest
is 18 so 2026
but then um
at the last minute he
changed his mind on that
so yeah so we'll be going to court in
the spring it looks like
i'm so sorry so how can we help today
what's your biggest pain point that
you're trying to figure out financially
yeah well just
i mean i i'm looking at this from an
emotional lens and
i think it would be helpful to look at
it
um
just more like financially like look at
the numbers
and um
see that i'm gonna be okay
even though it feels like i'm not gonna
be okay
well courtney hang on the line we're
gonna carry this through to the next
segment because i definitely don't want
to shortchange you while you're going
through something so so difficult so
hang on the line ken and i will walk you
through some next steps give you some
hope emotionally financially whatever
you need we are here for you and we'll
pick it back up after the break this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by ken
coleman before the break we were
chatting with courtney in boise and she
is going through a divorce about seven
months into the process
she's losing the house because she can't
afford it after the refinance they're
still dealing with the lawyers and who's
gonna get what and she was a
stay-at-home mom currently working at a
coffee shop and we are back with her
courtney how you doing
yeah okay
so let's continue where we left off here
so let's look at your financial picture
you told me earlier that you want to not
look at this emotionally right now but
just try to focus on the facts and the
finances to get on your feet
correct
right
okay
so let's walk through this thing what
are you most afraid of right now
financially
well
yeah i guess that i'll make a dumb
decision
and and i think
i think
um
i'm concerned for my kids and um i think
the house represents
the last stability
we we have and so
um
i think they're my my greatest concern
i can tell you've got a big heart of
course for your kids and that's the
biggest priority here do you know what's
what's going to happen with all of that
have you guys sorted that out
um
no well he he moved to another state
so i'll have full custody
and you said that he was going to pay
the mortgage instead of alimony through
2026 but now that's not happening
right because he he wants to buy a house
over there
so he won't be able to get
i guess a mortgage so that means you
will be getting alimony
um
i should be yeah okay but you don't know
how much yet
what's the what's the current mortgage
in the house that you're in what is it
costing you money uh it it's 1500 a
month okay
so if you have full custody you're at
the coffee shop have you looked into
what this looks like for child care and
the kids
um well
um
he'll be paid well
um
about 2 000 a month for
child support
okay um
yeah
and then
yeah
how much are you making right now from
the coffee shop
i'm making twelve dollars an hour right
how many hours are you oh
um oh probably 13 a week okay um so it's
definitely not a long term because i'm
going to need something
that will give me health insurance and
right a 40 hour you know i i just want
to ask you really quick george is going
to walk you through the numbers here but
i'm just curious if you are working
full-time
have you run some numbers on what you
would need to make to be able to keep
the home
well
um
yeah i guess it would just be what i
qualify for um
but
because i don't have much work history
um
my parents said they would co-sign on a
loan wait
how did we get into how did we get into
a loan you're already in a home you
already own a home and the mortgage is
1500 a month
so forget refinancing i'm just saying as
is whatever happens in the divorce how
much money would you have to make for
you to be able to pay the mortgage on
the current home that you own
well with the child support and alimony
i wouldn't have to be working full-time
if it was stayed at
right and that's assuming he pays
right
but if you work full-time and you took
ownership you said you know what i'm if
he pays it great but i'm going to work
full-time and if i made here's my point
you've got to run the exercise if do i
need to make 40 000 do i mean to make 50
000 do i need to make 60 000 sweetheart
and i know this is scary but we got to
talk real stuff here you're going to
have to start to go okay
what do i have to make
to keep the house let's at least look at
that let's not assume we have to sell
the house now selling the house might
take care of some debt that you two have
and i'll turn it back to you george but
i think she's got a we got to go okay i
can do this
that's your mindset you've got to be
able to say i can do this but in order
to feel confident about that to take the
emotion out of it because you've got
some natural fear and doubt
you're going to have to get some real
hard numbers here to go okay what would
it look like
to stay in the house which would keep
that stability and you don't have a big
move on top of everything else yeah
now courtney how many kids do you have
three three kids okay
so renting somewhere and trying to find
somewhere that could fit the whole gang
that could be tough
right yep now refinancing you're getting
he's got to get off of the the loan
through the refinance rights do you have
to refinance as part of the divorce
process
um that's the impression i have yeah
okay and then you're saying once you
refinance they're not going to let you
just remain on the loan by yourself
because you don't have the work history
the income history
correct yep that's what i'm hearing is
that true yeah as part of the divorce
process the refinance has to happen in
order to get someone off of the loan is
that right and so that's what i was
feeling with this situation oh okay so
there you go all right so still coming
out of the house all right so what i'm
wondering is let's say worst case you
sell the house and let's say you get
half of it what would that look like
how much money would that be
um
probably
um
three hundred thousand
that's your half what you would get
yeah wow okay well that's i mean that's
a good number that's very helpful with a
situation like this to have a pile of
cash
it is yeah i know it's it was a dream
house
i know that's what i'm feeling is you
said this is the last you know
represents the stability but it feels
like it represents
what once was and now we've got to paint
a picture of future courtney and she is
a rock star
single mom with three kids who is
amazing and
that that feels like it's a part of the
process
is that kind of what it is it's more of
an emotional thing than it is the actual
house itself
well
yeah
prompt yes
yeah
but you're going to be able to
have another amazing home one day that's
going to be yours
okay so i know it i know it's so hard
right now because you're in the middle
of this and you're you're letting go and
saying goodbye to this past life and
stepping into this new one but i want
you to start dreaming
as you grieve through this process about
what life looks like for courtney now
and do you have any debt
um no just the house well but before he
left he bought a new truck so
but that's not your debt is that
well i i think it's because it's a um
what's it called as a community
community of property state uh it's all
equal
so all the debts are split amongst you
that's that's what i'm thinking
i would talk to your lawyer about this
because i don't like the idea of you
having to pay his truck loan right i
don't either
so let's make sure that's not part of it
but let's just say you're debt-free do
you have any savings on your own have
you guys already split all the accounts
and everything
um no it's still together but um yeah we
have a few thousand in savings
i would i would separate these accounts
how far are you into the process as far
as finalizing the divorce
um we have a court date in april okay
well i'd work closely with your lawyer
and one thing i want to do before we've
gotta head to a break is connect you
with one of our ramsey financial coaches
who can walk with you at a deeper level
because it's hard to do in a seven
minute radio call and walk with you
along this journey because we we care
about you we're rooting for you
and we want to see you when financially
and
and figure out what this next chapter is
for you
and so they'll sit down with you
one-on-one you can do it virtually if
that makes you more comfortable but i'll
have kelly pick up and we'll get you a
financial coaching session on the books
and they will help you walk through this
very very messy process and i've been
through it myself courtney and this is
obviously way more difficult with all
the kids involved and the unknowns
you're just stepping into a lot of new
stuff right now
but it's going to get better and i can't
wait for you to call back
and let us know your progress and say
hey i've got my emergency fund in place
i've got a new house that i love
child care has been taken care of i've
got a career that i love and for that
side i want you to call into ken's show
when you're ready to talk about what
that looks like for you he would be more
than happy to talk you through it i
appreciate the call we love you courtney
we are wishing you the best through this
very very difficult process
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm
george campbell joined today by ken
coleman and we're taking your calls so
give us one i'm playing air piano right
now i just like that's the way i like it
from ken it feels very relaxing silent
piano from ken coleman there it is
perfect love the bump
well we're taking your calls folks
triple eight eight two five two 825-5225
is the number to call and tanner has
decided to do it he made it through he's
in phoenix arizona tanner welcome to the
ramsey show
hi guys how you guys doing doing great
how can ken and i help
good good i had a career question so i
have been in the medical marijuana
industry for about 11 years in a row now
as upper management i no longer want to
be in the career i want to do something
different you know i took your advice i
took a couple of your guys's courses
online i love them the proximity
principle i love it
i also downloaded your guys's resume
template so good for the last two months
i've been sending out some resumes and
unfortunately i have not even received a
single phone call
i was just wondering if you guys can
give me any advice as to breaking the
stigma of the marijuana industry and how
do i get in
to a different management role okay well
we got two different questions there
i'm not i'm not sure i'm an expert on
breaking the stigma of medical marijuana
i mean honestly i i don't know
i because largely i'm not sure i know
what the stigma is i mean
it's not like some new concept all of a
sudden you know what i mean um
but i'll come back to that one i'm gonna
table that one for now and come back to
that let's let's talk about
the second part of the question which is
how do i break through and start to get
some some some job interviews
um i i would stop just submitting
resumes unless and you may not have told
me everything but based on what you said
i'm assuming you're just sending out
resumes cold correct
yes yeah well that's like playing the
lottery okay
especially in today's world
so even small businesses tanner are
using you know artificial intelligent
type software
so that resume submissions and they've
got keywords so they're looking for
based on the job description that
they've posted and your resume
forget the cannabis experience that you
have in the medical marijuana side of
things
they're looking for keywords that relate
to the job description it's like really
specific and if you enter in that
artificial intelligence and the software
that people are writing
really great and qualified candidates
sometimes will get kicked out just
because your resume doesn't have enough
of the keywords related to their job
description does that make sense i want
to make sure i don't talk too much
technical but does that underst you
understand what i'm saying
yes yes i do so the reality is is you
and i don't have any evidences right now
that somebody's looking at your resume
and seeing that you've been in medical
marijuana for 11 years and they're going
oh we're not calling that guy back we
don't really have any evidence of that
do we
no okay then so you're limiting yourself
by saying well that's why no that may
not be why at all
but let's also recognize that some
people
may have some sort of issue with it and
a stigma i mean that happens so how do
we remove both situations we're not
getting looked at because we're
submitting cold resumes and we have a
resume that's got a lot of experience on
it that may carry a stigma with it
here's how we eliminate both of those
two factors being limiting
we are focusing on relationships
connections connections connections
and you have got to submit a resume
you're still going to have to submit it
online just like you have been before
but only after
you've got somebody
who is vouching for you who is
submitting your resume personally to
somebody that they know this is how you
get
through the uh what i would call the
online pile right in the old days you
took in a physical resume and it may sit
on the hiring manager's desk now
everything is digital but to get noticed
you're gonna have to have that personal
connection does that make sense
yes it does so when i you talked about
the proximity principle which is a book
i wrote a couple years ago also a
bestseller and and you read that book
yes
yes
well i hate to be so simplistic but you
got to go back in there and go okay wait
a second
what is it that i want to do fill in the
blank what is it that you're looking for
you've applied what kind of work you're
looking for
okay so i do know what i'm looking for
so
it is sending my resumes cold but
in my industry the thing that i really
the task i really love doing is supply
chain management and that's extremely
crucial to make sure we have all the
supplies and everything we need in our
facilities
after reading your book that's really
the only thing that drove me in our
industry so i would like to break away
from the cannabis industry and go to a
supply chain right or chain management
position so what so are you saying in
the phoenix arizona is that the big
circle we kind of draw a big circle on
the map in the greater phoenix area
that's where we want to look
uh yes okay great and there's plenty out
there there's of course they're working
on indeed and stuff like that you see
plenty of ads out there asking for
that style of career so without saying
any company names out loud
um you can think of the companies you've
applied to plus there's some other
companies that you're probably
interested in as well correct you got
them in your mind
yes all right so you'd have to think
about all the people you know
i mean you've been living in phoenix how
long uh 23 years now all right just for
fun exercise you ready
yes don't overthink this give me
ballpark numbers how many people
between close personal relationships
whether it be family friends
former co-workers close people then
acquaintances people that you know but
you don't doing life with them but if
you saw them on the street you said hi
they say hi to you so they're an
acquaintance
and then even some social media
connections in the phoenix area how many
people you say that you know
oh three or four thousand people three
or four thousand people all right how
many people do you think each one of
those people know
well probably two thousand at least as
well yeah i'm not good at math george
that's a lot of people well it gets
exponentially insane because those 2 000
people know another 2 000. now tanner i
backed i kind of backed you into this
because i want you to understand that
you know plenty of people you know
everybody you need to know to get the
job you know everybody you need to know
to make a connection to somebody in
these companies so the companies you've
applied to
that you didn't get any response at all
i want you to go back to the drawing
board plus all the new options and i
want you to start just playing this game
out i want you to talk to everybody that
you know get on social media and do it
email everybody that you know on
linkedin with a real email address not
the linkedin email address and say hey
i'm looking to get connected over this
company this company this company and
this company yeah do you know somebody
over there how well do you know him
would you be willing to introduce me to
him for a phone call a zoom or a coffee
tanner you starting to track with where
i'm going
yep yep and then here's what happens we
find the right connection and we get a
really strong recommendation before we
ever submit a resume maybe even a real
conversation with the hiring manager and
they go okay great and they know
something great about you they they have
a mutual connection where there's some
credibility that's how you're gonna go
about getting the gig and it doesn't
really matter i don't think that you're
that you've been in medical marijuana
you want to show your 11 years of
experience and how that supply chain
management logistics and everything you
did there makes you a great candidate
this is the hottest job market we've
ever seen and if nothing else i want you
to go to ziprecruiter.com
ken today
and upload your resume and let them go
to work for you as well george some
great advice there ken no i just wanted
to uh to add for tanner that the way i
got my job here as an intern attempt
started with a direct message on twitter
it did not start with my resume who was
that in a pile that was to one of our
personalities yeah and i started working
with them on social media and i had a
plan and i was excited and i was
persistent but not aggressive and
annoying and that turned into a phone
call with hr which turned into another
personality set that call up yes and so
what did the credibility of that
relationship mean to the hr people why
would they even do a call with you
i have no idea there's no connection
because of the connection of that
personality who said hey george is a not
a nut
george is sharp i like george i think
it's worth a phone call yes that changed
everything and that was a twitter dm
that was free by the way yeah and so
tanner you gotta get more creative and
there's a lot of ways to do this but
just sitting in the digital quagmire of
a resume pile not gonna cut it use that
connections use those connections that
you have get creative show them that
you're really hungry to do this kind of
work i'm slow clapping right here george
because you just said digital quagmire
you like that i like it because it's
actually true this is what the new world
is like when you submit a resume cold
without a relationship you are
essentially putting yourself in the
digital quagmire yes
i'm you know to impress ken coleman with
a word that's a big day because you've
got a lot of ten dollar words
it's amazing quagmire that puts this
hour of the ramsay show in the books my
thanks to my pal ken coleman all of you
listening out there america and the team
in the booth james childs our producer
kelly daniel our phone screener and
associate producer ben hill
running the board we appreciate you guys
so much we'll be back with you before
you know it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show
where we help you become healthy
relationally successful professionally
and peaceful financially i'm george
campbell joined this hour by my friend
ken coleman best-selling author and host
of the ken coleman show open phones this
hour give us a call triple eight eight
two
825-5225
we can talk about your work your
relationships your money all of the
questions that rattle around in your
head that keep you up at night the
frustrations at your job the toxic
workplace the debt that seems to never
go away
the retirement that you dream of we can
talk about all of it triple eight eight
two five five two two five heidi kicks
off this hour in columbus ohio heidi
welcome to the ramsay show
thanks for taking my call absolutely how
can ken and i help
so i've been kind of just
sitting here going over this much this
month's budget and i use the over dollar
app and i'm starting to see this lagging
problem that we're having and that is we
have a very high deductible um insurance
that we pay so
we have eleven thousand dollar out of
pocket max but we have to hit four
thousand dollars before it kicks into
ninety ten but once we're short my
husband had major surgery at the end of
last year he's still recovering
two of my kids had to have some
procedures done so guess what we've
already got
medical
bills out the wazoo from last year and
now already this year already we've
already hit 4 000 in bills and i'm a
stay-at-home mom so this is where we're
getting caught though my kids have a lot
of health needs that some of them are in
there a couple therapies a week special
issues um they're all five and under so
um
you know i'm trying to figure out if
emma could think of any other way you
know to find jobs i'm just i'm
struggling and i'm feeling really
discouraged by my husband we were just
making bye we were we were trying to
stay on a budget but every month like
the bills just keep piling up and we
don't know how to keep our money
spreading out when it just keeps going
going going
well here's the deal we can we can
figure this out i know it's overwhelming
but we got to get realistic and say okay
how much time do you actually have
or how much time are you going to need
to make
to then be able to make money so give me
a ballpark not holding you to this this
is an exercise how many hours do you
have uh in a given week including
weekend days to make some money for a
season
i would say
probably a max would be about 10 hours a
week to be very honest just because my
husband can't drive since his injury and
so it's me you know doing everything
around the house okay all right so let's
get realistic there all right so 10
hours a week that's that's the max you
have
if you if you made 20 an hour you'd be
pretty thrilled with 20 an hour wouldn't
you
yeah yeah but that would be but that's
200 bucks a week right yep and then
let's add that out so i mean is that
going to make a huge difference i'm
guessing anything helps but how much of
a difference if we just play this out
we're just playing round numbers now
um how much would uh let's call it 800
a month or a thousand dollars a month on
a five-week month how much of a
difference would that make
that would probably help since the
medical bills right now are still
sitting at
5500 from last year and now 4 000 this
year you know that would help at least
put more towards the medical bills
it would make a dent if we're looking at
that a month okay all right so the
challenge is you got to do that from
home
right so i could tell you there are
part-time jobs
uh where you could make
15 to 20 an hour but they're not at home
so when you start looking at home um you
have to start looking at things like
virtual assistant but again
um you know i don't you know that's if
you can do that so someone who's
organized but virtual assistant has
become a really great opportunity for
for folks that make money at home
virtually doing you know executive
assistant roles but again is somebody
looking for just 10 hours a week but
that is one that can get you
a pretty nice hourly rate
there's a sales function right so what
kind of at home sales if somebody if
they've got a good product they've got
good leads and they're just looking for
somebody to put in the hours the 10
hours you got to start looking for
things like that because this is less
about what you really enjoy and this is
actually more about what you can do and
we're looking at talent only because
this is
where this is you know bearing down for
a season we got to bring in some income
and so you want to be thinking
uh what are you best at doing what are
your talent and experience buckets
that's what you need to be looking for
right now because it gives you the best
chance to be successful you only have 10
hours
so
if you get something that's 15 an hour
that's what you're looking at
so your ideas uh need to be around you
know talent and experience
right so there are plenty of blogs and
you know we've got one christy wright
had done one you know at ramsey
solutions on you know 25 things you can
do from home there's all kinds of lists
and so you've got to start matching up
at home work things you can do from home
that match up with your talent
you can do transcription services
customer service rep like ken mentioned
you can do tutoring virtually and there
are a lot of options out there but i
would take a good look at your skill set
what you're able to do
and start to do some research on what
would be a viable option for you knowing
you've got 10 hours a week now what's
the household income
it's about 60 000. okay and is your
husband able to work anymore
he i asked him about today he said he
possibly could he can't pick up any work
at his work because it's all salary but
he could possibly when he gets his foot
repaired like maybe do some ubering he
was even thinking about doing some
instacart shopping
i was gonna recommend that if you've got
someone who can do that outside the home
you can make uh you know 20 30 bucks
easily an hour with shipped and
instacart and all these kind of delivery
services without even having to have
anyone in your car so that could be a
real flexible thing where he can turn on
the app for two hours after work and
it's gonna be a lot of late nights long
days but this is what it's gonna take to
get out of this mess all right hi so
let's just dive into this really quick
let's not think let's just rattle off
the top of your head what would you say
your top two or three skills that you
know if somebody paid you to do it you
could do it
sure i'm i'm very organized i've worked
as a secretary i've done finance but
that's my degree i love to teach
um i even love to do fitness
i am
i love to talk to people so that would
always be something right
all right so i just want to give you a
couple ideas to get the brainstorming
started okay
so i heard very organized so actually
the first idea i threw out there i think
is a viable option for you and i think
you need to look into virtual assistant
i think you also need to challenge
yourself a little bit and go could i
give someone 20 to 30 hours because at
the end of the day if it's emails and
organization doing stuff if the kids are
in bed i mean you got to buckle down
both you and your husband have got to
get this medical stuff fixed and get our
income as a whole up and then we're
going to be okay so this is just a
season i like the idea of the virtual
assistant i like the idea of online
teaching online teaching is exploding
there might not be that much of a
qualification process um there might be
i don't know you need to look into
online instruction and teaching i would
also look into customer service roles
because you said you like talking to
people and customer service you know if
you could pick up 10 to 15 hours a week
getting paid a nice hourly rate doing
customer service that could be nice yeah
heidi how much debt total do you guys
have
uh we have about 12 000 between all the
medical bills and um a car this is
nothing more paid off
it feels like you just can't get the
water out of the boat because there's a
hole in there but man we're going to
patch this thing up we're going to get
on the budget income george more income
more income is kind of how does this
boat up there 12 000 you can get rid of
this this year it's going to be gone
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm
george camel joined by my friend ken
coleman we are taking your calls on work
on life on relationships on money you
name it triple eight eight two five five
two two five
carol joins us in providence rhode
island carol welcome to the ramsay show
hey thank you all for having me i
appreciate it absolutely i gotta ask the
accent plus rhode island i'm very
confused
as a new englander myself
no it's from south carolina ah okay that
makes more sense all right okay how can
we help
hey we have a question for you my
husband is sitting here with me we
purchased the house a couple years ago
for 372.
we can now sell it for around 600 000
maybe a little bit more um
the problem that we have is is one we're
not really in the position to buy a
different property
for us to live in but if we sell this
property it's always been a rental so we
would have to pay capital gains on it so
would it be better for us to continue
baby step two and hold on to the house
and not pay capital gains and maybe do
like a 1031 exchange which our
accountant had mentioned
or
you know sell the house pay the capital
gains get out of debt and
you know that's kind of where we're
stuck at how much debt do you have
we have about a hundred and twenty
thousand what kind of that
um some credit cards um a couple cars
twenty thousand in student loans nothing
it's nothing really major major like you
know debt like that what's your
household income
um three hundred thousand whoa
so
before we go selling property what are
we doing with the three hundred thousand
dollars that we can't pay down all this
debt real fast well
i knew that was coming and i'm prepared
for that answer we just started making
this this was a blessing okay and my
husband had a huge promotion and a huge
raise and we're not even used to making
this
so
you know it's all everything is all new
to us that's awesome well i know he's
sitting there telling him that we said
congratulations this is fantastic so
here's the thing carol you're not in a
dire situation you don't make 60k and
you got 200k in debt and this house is
gonna solve all your problems uh i and
you said this is a rental property that
you guys are living in
we're not living in it we we purchased
it to live in it
and then we kind of had some things fall
through and we ended up having to put it
immediately as soon as we bought it to a
rental property
right now the rent that we get it rents
as soon as it hits market so it's in a
great location
and right now it covers the mortgage
they're fixing to put it up to market um
value so we'll actually be making
probably about a 600 on top of what our
mortgage is so
okay and where you got are you guys
living in a primary residence with
another mortgage on top of that
no that's the thing my husband's job
travels
and so
so you're ready basically yeah yeah
we're renting right now yeah okay well
if i'm in your shoes i'm not going to
get rid of this property and go through
the hassle of that and the capital gain
everything you mentioned when you now
make 300 000 and you owe 120. what i
will do is start to get on a budget make
sure that we've got our emergency our
thousand dollar starter emergency fund
and then i'm gonna get to work on that
debt snowball listing everything
smallest to largest regardless of the
interest rate and attack it with a
vengeance
okay
let me ask you this are you traveling
with your hubs when he's traveling
oh yes sir yeah we do
we thought we were going to settle down
a couple years ago but it just didn't
happen that way
and you know fortunately we were able to
buy this house in a great location and
it's what we what happened actually
turned into a blessing for us yeah so
worked it all out how what is the rhythm
right now in in
how long you guys are in a certain place
before you move to the next
well right now we're here indefinitely
um unless something changes but this is
not where we want to be we
want to be in florida
we want to be in florida where's the
house that we had to retire where's the
house is actually an air it's in arizona
okay
i've got a long distance landlord
situation i too yeah but yeah we have a
property manager that manages it for us
okay all right now george
you're the money guy we can disagree but
i'm excited about it i'm co-hosting here
so i'm going to weigh in here
i just wonder because
this house in arizona is not in their
long-term plans yeah do you guys want to
be long-term real estate investors
uh
probably not i just heard the hubs in
the background he's like now so i guess
here's my point i george and i'm serious
i
because it is not their primary
residence because it's in arizona and
they're making 600 a month it's not a
huge number it's not changing your life
they've got huge equity in it if i heard
correctly yeah what's the equity if you
sold today for 600 what would you net
we were probably 300 000 is what we
would we would get from it all right i'm
just going to give you another option i
would sell that house because you're not
in fee you're not in arizona you're
long-distance landlords you're not
making that much money
it's a hassle for not much
not much return monthly and yet you've
got tremendous equity and and by selling
that house
you guys are debt free
plus the new big income oh my gosh i'm
selling it
i'm putting on the market today
the only catch to that is is that the
price of the house is jumping five six
thousand dollars every 30 days i know
but yeah but okay so play that out this
is like timing the market where you go
well my my stocks are doing well so i'm
going to leave them in for another six
months imagine go up even more yeah
imagine being debt free now let me just
say this george's george's option is a
good option he's right you guys make
really good money if you get serious
about your budget i'm saying is you
don't need to sell it sometimes i go oh
my gosh it's time to sell it and i agree
with you is what i'm saying but my point
is is that i i'm telling you what i
would do i'd fast forward and i'd pay
off the i'd pay off the debt but if you
guys say no i like this and it's going
to keep going up every 30 days for who
knows how long you still got to play
that out and go all right but we got to
pay our debt
so it would be worth it to pay the
capital gains you think on that because
we would definitely have to you're
saying even if you paid capital gains
you would net 300.
oh no that's no not after capital gains
no i think capital gains would be 15 or
20 percent of the profit right i still
would do it but that's me i mean george
gave you a very viable option you guys
have the income to be able to pay off
your 120 grand
but but my point is is why keep
something
that's long distance that's only making
you 600 bucks a month when it can be
turned into something that actually fast
forward your wealth
yeah it's not 600 a month we the the
rent that we rented for is 2300 and it's
fixing to go up to 3 000 a month
no no i said you said it in there i
thought you said you're making 600 a
month after you pay the cash flow
mortgage yes you did oh okay maybe i
said it wrong i don't know it does pay
yeah you're right it does pay the
mortgage the mortgage is 22 and then
they're fixing to put it up so i guess
we would bring home five or six hundred
that's what came out
that's what i'm referring to so ken's
saying hey that's about what six grand a
year that's not life-changing numbers
when you make 300 yeah so that's not a
reason to hang on to it but what
life-changing is is getting out of debt
as quickly as you could and now you're
building up well you guys have any
savings no that's the goal i feel like i
need to tell you what our goal is
i make this kind of money
i work a lot
i want to get debt free and if i can
manage it on this kind of money retire
in 10 years i don't know if that's
feasible or not
it is if you guys take advantage of this
income
and if you know i think you sell the
house i mean if you sell this thing and
pay off your debt if you let's say you
net 300 just ballpark numbers you get
rid of the debt you're left with 180 000
you told me you don't have much in
savings we got to get you guys a fully
funded emergency fund of three to six
months let's just call it 30 grand 40
grand does that sound good
so at that point you still have 140
grand left that you could put in index
funds and while you guys are living this
transient life let that grow for you and
then when you're ready for florida
you're going to be able to pay cash for
a home which is going to help you build
that uh that your assets up so that you
can retire with dignity and have an
awesome retirement
sell the house by the way we haven't
even touched your 300 000 in income so
put that to work don't live on less than
you make continue to live exactly as
you've been living before you made this
kind of money and you will be
multi-millionaires
you can do this
in long-distance homeowners
that's right that's what i'm saying sell
the house sell it i could listen to
those access all day long george tilly
sell it thank you sell it thanks for the
call carol appreciate you guys this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
hate to be the bearer of bad news but it
is tax time folks and many of you have
been filing your taxes with the same
software for years but are you sick and
tired of add-on fees you've probably
seen all the ads saying it's free to do
your taxes with the big companies but
the reality is that for most people it's
not free and by the time you realize
that you don't meet the free criteria
you put in too much time to start over
somewhere else so you pay up but listen
they're making a killing off of you that
way and we think you deserve better
that's why we're offering ramsey smart
tax so you can file your taxes online
without paying more than you'd expect
ramsey smart tax includes every form you
need with no hidden fees and no
surprises we even have a promo code
right now so you can file your federal
taxes for free and if you prefer to have
priority support and extended audit
protection you can go with our premium
version for just 20 bucks so if you're
ready to ditch the other guy surprising
fees and save on your taxes head to
ramseysolutions.com smart tax and get
started today for free that's ramsay
solutions.com
smart tax i'm george campbell joined
today by ken coleman open phones this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five greg joins us from new york
city the big apple greg welcome to the
ramsay show
greg you're with us thanks guys yeah how
can we help
so i got a question about the term life
insurance
and i got married five years ago we
purchased term life insurance and
based on salary increases we've already
gone above the 10 to 12 times
so basically my question is how do we
determine how much more to get if for
instance my salary if you know speaking
with bosses and my trajectory my career
i could see my salary possibly doubling
within the next five years
so right now i've got a million dollar
out term policy i make 109 but if i
could possibly be making you know 150 to
200
based on promotions
would you suggest for uh the next policy
upgrade
well the easy situation here is just to
get more term life and you can do that
you can just add another policy there
for let's say you went to 200 well you
could just add another million dollar
policy to get you to 10 times your
income
so do you i mean
are you trying
i'm just trying to think like do you
limit how many times you're adding a
policy because you know as you get older
the prices go up and then you know
potential health differences and whatnot
or
sure i mean you're saying should i limit
how much i get because i don't need 20
years
10 years from now i don't want to sign
up for another 20-year policy
well i guess a secondary question which
is you know the 15 to 20 years i'm 32
so if i can't take any money out of
retirement you know or my wife can't
either until 59 and a half
you know wouldn't we want to be closer
to 30
to take it to do well
if you follow the baby steps then after
that 15 20 year you are going to be what
we call self-insured
because you will have a paid for home
and you're going to have lots of money
in your investment account because of 20
years of compounded growth if you've
been investing for that period of time
and so at that point there's not a lot
of expenses to rely on if something
happened to you
then your wife would be okay because
she's got a paid for home and she's got
a big old pile of investments that she
would then inherit and be able to use
okay understood so it's that simple so
you can go get connected to
ramseysolutions.com and click on trusted
pros and get in touch with xander and
they can shop the best rates for you on
that term life policy and i'm going to
have ken jump in here as well
well you know i listen i don't have any
money advice on this one but i get some
real life anecdotes for granted i'm here
for this is real so greg you're only 32.
uh i remember i think it was two years
ago
uh
you know because we use we all use
zander here at ramsey solutions all of
us and we got a uh email from saying hey
uh life insurance rates you know are
like really really low
and um you know i've got three teams
and so with income and everything i was
like i need to bump up and so greg i
just want to encourage you on this like
how often do you do it it's really not
that big of a deal like uh and here's
what i found out
greg i found out that rates were really
really great and if i got like the
unbelievable preferred you know like
health status that it was going to even
be lower
so i kid you not i
i think i fasted for like three to five
days wow yeah like really like and we're
exercising working out for about a month
up to like gotten super that's just kind
of rocky routine going on here just
tightened up a little bit yeah because
you want that blood score you know and
so it was great it was great and i got
the absolute preferred rate save even
more money look at life hack just don't
eat for four days before you get it no
no no no no that's not going to do it
but i'm saying like you're getting
really great shape yeah greg you're a
healthy guy you're a healthy guy or if
you get healthier 10 years from now do
that
you get lower rates the healthier you
are
yeah it makes sense yeah i appreciate it
all right greg's excited
this is the big stuff you come to the
show for that kind of yeah that kind of
happened ken talking about how he
tightened up that's what we all want to
hear
listen
you get a health exam yeah and now they
do them without health exams which is
interesting what yeah it's a it's a new
thing all the kids are doing it ken it's
all the rage because i had to go through
the full blood test same same not doing
this this is your version of i had to
walk uphill both ways back in my day
it's so true well first of all that hack
is now irrelevant you're right yeah i
mean there you still do exams but there
are versions where you can do uh do it
without the health exam so a lot of
options out there you can get connected
with our friends at xander if you guys
are interested in term life george
you're so smart i'm here for you ken
ben joins us in spokane washington ben
welcome to the show
hey thank you so much for having me sure
how can we help
all right my name is ben i'm 19. i have
about 10 000 in investments and about
five thousand dollars in cash and i'm
debt free
i just recently got my first credit card
and i'm having a really hard time
going against my saving instinct uh it
was just something my parents kind of
pressured me into getting
and i just am having a really hard time
understanding
why i need this un
tangible thing called credit ben you are
speaking my how do i overcome this okay
so the truth is and uh your parents are
very well meaning and they love you but
they fell for the trap and here's the
trap telling your kid they have to get a
credit card and why did they tell you to
get a card ben
uh to build up credit boom to get your
credit score up and why do you need a
high credit score
to pay for a house
to get a loan
to get loans
that's the only thing you need a credit
score for and the truth is you don't and
i can tell you this because i am a
practitioner of this i was able to get
my mortgage which is now paid off
without any credit score
wow is that shocking so
why
does
everyone just seem to have a credit card
then it just
it seems then we are asking the same
question every day on the rams it's
called marketing think about how i want
you to watch tv the next three or four
nights you youngsters don't watch
network tv watch how many commercials
there are for a credit card
it's insane there's a lot a lot do you
would your parents sit down and listen
to a podcast with you just one episode
yeah okay
i'm gonna point you in the direction of
my podcast the fine print episode seven
is called the dirty truth behind your
credit score and if you want to talk
credit card rewards episode two is
titled the true cost of credit card
rewards so if you want to have a fun
hour listen to both of those episodes
with them and we dig into all of those
myths about credit and your parents are
are not dumb people they're smart but
they just fell for the normal american
traps of well you got to have your
credit score to build your credit and
how do you do that well you got to go
into debt and you got to pay it
perfectly and get more debt so you can
get a perfect credit score but
everything that they say you can't do
without a credit score
i have done i am like a unicorn ken it's
amazing i rent cars i rent hotels i
bought a house i pay cash for cars which
means they don't need to look at my
credit score which by the way is
invisible ben are you hearing this
george is living outside the matrix
of the fine print i'm not kidding you
your parents will actually like it
george is very entertaining as you can
see it's a blast it's a great listen and
i think it'll be fun now don't sit there
and go i told you mom and dad let him
listen to it and process it but then as
soon as the episode is done i want you
to cut up the credit card in front of
them
and say i love you guys
in my hand okay well do it do it after
the episode film it and then send it to
me on instagram george campbell i'd love
to see that this is gonna be fun i can't
wait ben thanks so much for the call man
you're doing great but don't fall for
the traps this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
isaiah 54 10. though the mountains be
shaken and the hills be removed yet my
unfailing love for you will not be
shaken nor my covenant of peace be
removed says the lord who has compassion
on you henry ford said the whole secret
of a successful life is to find out what
is one's destiny to do and then do it
i bet ken coleman loves that quote
sounds familiar doesn't it yeah um
figure out what you're what you were
born to do man good stuff there
all right matt joins us this hour in
indianapolis matt welcome to the show
hello thank you so much for having me on
absolutely how can can i help
so i'm a college sophomore
i've been fortunate enough for my
parents to be able to
pay for my education so i have no debt
um i have a little bit over five
thousand dollars in investments in
mutual funds
uh about 1800 in the bank um
and i'm getting married in may so i'm
excited about it hey
congratulations oh thank you
um now the issue is uh after graduating
um and bearing being married and we're
probably going to have a roughly around
150 190 000 in student loan debt
um now you said you didn't have that is
this
i i don't it is um yeah it's from um her
but from what we say i do it's sure
okay i just want to make sure
what field is she going into
uh public relations
wow
and it was about 200 grand in
student loan debt for her
uh on the high end it's difficult for us
to get an exact estimate at the moment
we're working with
some experts in our area who
kind of understand how much we can get
in
federal grants or in scholarship money
once we're married right now it's a
little bit difficult for us to estimate
that that could help lower that news
yes
um but my question is uh i have a little
over five thousand dollars in
investments for retirement
um
so i was wondering if i should move that
over into
um the student loan debt the
moment we get married or should i let
that accumulate interest
um hold it for retirement or
um
put it into that debt a little bit later
you're saying these are retirement
accounts is this an ira or a 401k
um
not actually at the moment uh right now
it's just a taxable brokerage fund
at the moment it is yes the plan was to
change that after college i didn't know
if i'd need the cash sooner or later
okay okay you were worrying me there i
don't want you to touch it if it's
actually retirement accounts but you're
saying you were just saving for
retirement
for the most part yeah okay all right if
this is just a taxable brokerage account
this is not retirement meaning you're
not going to pay penalties on this
then yes i would cash it out once you
guys are married and use that to kick
start the debt payoff
okay when are you guys getting married
uh the end of uh this coming may okay
and you're not working yet
um
not at the moment we do have um various
campus jobs
and we also i have an internship uh this
summer at a major attraction in pigeon
forge
and then she's applying for internship
down there as well um so we will have
cash flow throughout the summer and also
throughout
the school years we'll have a small cash
flow what's your major what's your
career going to be once you graduate and
get a job
i'm currently a double major marketing
and business management
with a minor in computer systems
and i'm going into theme park management
so
i'm looking to be making hopefully
around um 45 to 50 000 out of college um
with growth potential out of that okay
and you assume she'll hopefully get a
job in public relations and be making
something similar to you
uh yeah okay
well that puts you guys at you know
probably let's just say round numbers
100 grand for your gross income
and then you've got a pile of debt
that's 150. so this is this is a
mountain and you guys can do this but
you're gonna need to possibly work some
side jobs and get that income up as fast
as possible because i want you to pay
off this debt very quickly i don't want
this to be a six seven year journey for
you guys
yeah that's definitely the goal um and
we're definitely of the rice and beans
mindset we already have a worst-case
scenario and best case scenario budget
set out for the summer
my parents are
baby steps millionaires who teach
financial peace um so we've been willing
those things over time
but the main question is just over those
investments about whether i should hold
them or yeah if they're not actually
retirement i would just cash those out
as you guys get married and
use that to make a dent in this these
student loans
okay perfect thank you so much
appreciate the question matt
all right moving on we are headed to
little rock arkansas stephanie joins us
there stephanie welcome to the show
are you with us stephanie did you make
it
we lost stephanie oh there we go talk to
me stephanie nice and clear directly
into your phone
okay can you hear me now yes
okay
um okay so i'm calling because my
husband and i are in a little bit of a
debate
so um let me just give you a little
background of where we're at we're both
50
and we plan to work about another 10
years
um
the only debt we have right now is our
home
and
it's valued at about 225 000 and we only
owe 164 on it okay
and i see my my husband's gonna be able
to retire from this job in about a year
and a half he'll get another job doing
something else but when he retires he
will have a receive a pension
um or you want an amount it's like do
you want me to know how much okay um he
we have about a hundred and ten thousand
in a 401k we have about 90 000 in an ira
and he'll probably receive around 400
000 for his pension if he makes it the
full 100 uh when one and a half years
the thing is we're just in a really
volatile time right now we're not sure
if he'll make it the full time because
they're laying off like crazy but we're
praying that he's gonna make it we're
thinking with the positive uh
you know with our faith and everything
and believing that he'll make it the
full year and a half so we're going to
look at it from that perspective okay so
what's the argument
okay so the argument is he
how he listens to you guys all the time
i listen when i can but i'm a teacher so
i'm not going to be able to listen as
much as he does so um he works from home
so he can just put something on while
he's working so he
um
has been understanding you guys are
saying pay off your home pay off your
home get out of debt completely yes okay
well my thinking is
um that we should
take the money invest it and then take
all the dividends and pay extra on the
home
and probably get it paid off in
10 years or so as well as the extra
payments we already pay on our home so
okay so that's it that's pretty much it
what's left on the mortgage
uh 164.
it's going to take you 10 years to pay
off 164 thousand dollars well you know
we don't have any other debt and we both
make pretty good
so if we
maybe it'll take longer than 10. what's
your household number 15
almost 200 000
hold on i'm just so confused you make
two hundred thousand dollars and you're
going to wait 10 years to pay off 160k
well yeah i mean we still have other
things that we do we our household bills
and stuff
sure you could put a big chunk on this
mortgage every month
yes that's true and you guys have no
debt right you got no debt and you have
an emergency fund
that's true yes we do have three kids so
there's expenses how much are you
putting extra on it you said you're
already doing putting extra on the on
the mortgage what are you doing we pay
about a payment and a half a year extra
you can do better than that
i'm going to push you guys
you could probably making 200k
i mean it's time to are you guys doing a
monthly budget together we do
okay i mean make sure you know four five
six we're doing 15
into retirement no more than that we're
then putting some money away for kids
college
nothing crazy
and then we're putting everything extra
we have all the margin we can onto the
house
okay and if you do that start using the
mortgage calculator the payoff
calculator at ramseysolutions.com and
make a plan
not just wishing and hoping that it gets
paid off in 10 years go you know what
we're going to put this much a month and
two years from now three years from now
this mortgage is gone
and once with that's gone now the rest
of our working career we can sock up for
retirement and we're gonna have an
awesome life but right now we're trying
to do a lot of things at once using the
dividend money to pay off the house and
all kinds of things so that's what i
would do that's our plan and if you do
it that way you're going to thank me
later appreciate the call that puts this
hour of the ramsey show in the books my
thanks to my co-host my co-pilot ken
coleman our team in the booth james
childs ben hill kelly daniel and you
america thank you guys so much for
listening we'll be back with you before
you know it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you